happy cinemacon happy Cinema yeah it's
our first time here we're super excited
thanks for having me tell me about the
moment you found out hey I'm gonna be in
Blue Beetle what was that moment like
yeah I have it yeah a lot of crying how
would you feel if I told you that we
would like for you to be our journey in
Blue Beetle
you'll have to answer the question
I would feel so grateful yeah I was just
super excited coming from Brazil this is
not something that I'm I'm that happens
all the time that I'm used to so it was
a really emotional beautiful moment oh
amazing
and he'll surprised me we were having
dinner together and he said do you like
steak and I said yeah I like steak we're
at a steakhouse and he said do you want
to be Blue Beetle and I said wow you
really set that one up crazy there and
then I started crying of course and uh
the rest was history
[Music]
what was the experience like being out
there it was great it was amazing we
all the time we got to see an extended
version of the trailer extended version
of the trailer I blacked out so I don't
remember any of it but it was a it was a
great time it was it was really great to
see all the the DC fan movies coming out
this year and and yeah
yeah I like how you have your your Blue
Beetle yeah I did my Blue Beetle now oh
that's amazing oh my gosh okay I'm doing
this for the premiere right elsewhere at
silicon we also have a close look at the
suit which is awesome tell me about some
of the qualities of this suit
uh type
um
no I mean the great thing about the Blue
Beetle suit is that it really is as
creative as Jaime can be the universe
has sent you a gift and you have to
figure out what you're going to do with
it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
let's party you know the the fun is as
we saw in the trailer is that you get to
make the big Buster Cloud swords and we
get to do the blasters and the maces and
and Jaime has a really great imagination
and getting to explore that
um onset you know practically was really
fun getting to you know work with
different shaped you know various
objects in your hands is really great uh
but I think we're just gonna have to
wait to the movie to see just how
crazy it is if you could conjure up
anything with your own Scarab what would
you something with food it'd be some
like instant chilakile maker or
something in my hand maybe I could get
like some frying pans on my hands and
make a grilled cheese yes
yes anything anything food anything
Brazilian food I must admit I'm a very
big Cobra Kai fan I think it's an
amazing show and you obviously had some
amazing sensei's on that set to kind of
guide you along the way so for this
experience who who did you kind of rely
on for the the Blue Beetle knowledge
Angel the director was a beacon of light
throughout this whole project I you know
this is my first movie so it felt
daunting at some moments but he is so
particular and really trustworthy and
and just allowed you know as actors for
us to come on and do our thing Bruna is
another amazing friend that I've made
over over the course of this journey and
uh even though it feels like it went
like a blink uh I hope that I get to
work together with everyone we better do
a second one
yeah I don't watch it with the tide
shifting and the Peter saffron and the
James Gunn it goes okay what happens
from here so it seems like you know
they're saying this is a standalone if
this does well we're going to keep it
going yeah yeah I mean I I think
the great thing about Blue Beetle is
that we've kind of conjured it as a
standalone so I think it's nice to get
to you know explore this character but
yeah and it's success we're ready to to
fold in all the characters into the rest
but but at the very least you know I
feel as the work has already been done
you know I the really the main thing is
opening doors for for more people so as
once the movie comes out like it's it's
out of our hands it's called this
carrots it's some kind of world
destroying weapons it's designed to
protect the toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it does it are you're an
original character
yeah
it's not this it's quite the same Jenny
yeah I think Jenny is is closely
connected to a lot of characters that we
know and love uh but no you're you're
bringing Jenny to the character to the
screen for the first time ever
yeah it was really fun to kind of
develop this own character that's just
Uniquely Yours everything
everything was just so fun about it
um but I I mean I'm I fell in love with
a character she's great she has great
values and I can't say I can't say much
I'm I'm terrified we got the DC people
on the other side of this with the
ticking Time Bomb if we say anything
yeah you're uh you're uh
woman in a position of power yes which
is great which is great
um
yeah I can't I can't say but yeah yeah
that's it that's all I can say about
Janie cord I think he likes me
[Applause]
Jaime gets his powers in front of his
entire family what was that experience
like for you just kind of working with
this family that scene where I'm going
through the transformation on the first
time was done on my 21st birthday yeah
yeah that was done on my 21st birthday
so it was really exciting and you know
you would think that for a family who's
supposed to have had you know 20 years
of chemistry that you know a week of
meeting them wouldn't be enough but the
whole family we fit together like a
glove and and even with the
incorporation of some of our other
characters who aren't part of the
immediate family it felt so natural from
the get-go and I think it's so
that's one of the most Charming parts of
the movie is that like you said the
family is is looped in from day one they
provide him I think a great shoulder to
to kind of lean on amidst this crazy
Journey that this young man has to you
know kind of take along but where I'm so
grateful that he has a good support
system in his family yeah
[Music]